j'ai levé les bras dans la plus
prestigieuse organisation de mon sport
c'est vraiment un rêve c'est ce que je
veux marc-andré barioz a fait son entrée
dans la ufc en 2019
depuis il a livré trois combats qu'il a
tous perdus de combos l'on peut voir ça
comme étant le combo la dernière chance
il doit absolument gagner s'ils ne veut
pas mettre un terme à son aventure dans
la plus grande ligue mondiale d'arts
martiaux mixtes
cet ultime affrontement aura lieu à las
vegas le 20 juin contre le polonais
oscar piotta poursuit préparer le poids
moyen qui vit à québec et revenu dans sa
ville natale gatineau et pandémie oblige
il vit seul dans sa roulotte
en fait ça c'est ma maison depuis
quasiment deux semaines que je suis à
vis à gatineau on aime entraîner
j'étais un gars qui aime bien avant sa
bulle c'est un peu pour ça que je suis
venu ici pour tout ses meilleures amies
gatinois ont tous mis de côté pour
l'entraîner julien leblanc combattant
professionnel d'arts martiaux mixtes et
le champion du monde les to et la boxe
birmane des bleus du
[Musique]
leur marque
à 28 ans le duc est une légende vivante
au miam
plus de la moitié des 50 millions
d'habitants du pays ont regardé son
dernier combat la boxe birmane reconnu
comme le sport le plus violent de la
planète est interdite au canada
tous les coups sont permis le luxe vite
aujourd'hui à chypre et au mois de mars
il était passage à gatineau
ça fait dix ans qu'on se connaît on a
commencé leur fighting à gatineau
tous ensemble puis on était tout amateur
en temps fait que c'est comme un retour
aux sources
on est tous derrière lui on veut tous
qu'ils reçoivent un truc qui résolution
de tout qui gagne ce combat là c'est un
peu comme le film qu'ils ont ça entraîne
un peu dans l'ombre
et pour vraiment et rayonner lorsque ce
sera le cas en période de pandémie
impossible de respecter la distanciation
quand on pratique les arts martiaux
mixtes et toutes les salles de
conditionnement physique la province
sont fermés
marc-andré barioz profile donc des
installations disponibles sans trop
attirer l'attention
j'ai pas le choix de fixer les règles en
même temps moi c'est un athlète
professionnel j 6 1 contre eur on me
demande de les combattre dans deux
semaines ben je peux pas le faire sans
entraînements sinon je mets ma santé
encore plus en jeu je pense donc
l'entente c'est que moi que les
personnes qu'on ici c'est vraiment
restreint on je demande aux gars qu'ils
fassent attention à l'extérieur - celui
qu'on surnomme pas albarn est
aujourd'hui tout en oeuvre pour gagner
ce combat qui sera peut-être sa dernière
chance de réaliser son rêve de plus
guère voir s'ils sont bonnes entre
cambodgiens un jour faire un combat
parfait je donnerais pas aucun point et
et je veux gagner par décision il peut
pas se permettre ça il doit défendre
pendant 15 min doit le le maître corot
jeu de lego histoire sanglante et c'est
tout gentil mal
tu es pauvre bonhomme de longue date bob
des plus beaux la fight
c'est là puisque jamais que je joue
vraiment les chercher ma paye qu'il veut
mais pas d'un appui de leurs 18 trous
quai comme c'est marc-andré c'est moi le
vrai le pig aux anges en veut donc là
[Musique]